- Everyone I knew, I felt like had
the most wonderful experience
after they had their baby
but I didn't know how
to say I'm freaking out.
- Postpartum depression to me is
the disconnect you have with your baby.
- An overwhelming, uncontrollable
sense of anxiety.
- One of many mental illnesses
that can affect mothers.
- When I got pregnant, I
was instantly in a bad mood.
In addition to that, I had fibroids,
which are tumors that grow in your uterus
and it was really scary.
- I knew I had postpartum depression
the first time when I went to go
and pump my breast milk at work
and I just broke down crying.
- I actually remember
saying to my husband,
"You know, people kept
saying I'd be so emotional
"and I feel fine," and the reality
of the situation was that I was
completely emotionally numb.
- Right after I had the baby, it was
my husband's birthday
so I baked him a cake
and I invited people over.
And people were like,
"What are you doing?"
But I felt like it was my duty
to celebrate his
birthday, to try to nurse,
and then come back and
put on a happy face.
- I believed that every parent around me
knew what they were
doing and that I was this
devastating failure.
- When my son was four months old,
and I remember breast feeding him
but he wouldn't stop crying
and I got face to face with him
and I screamed, "Stop crying."
That was probably the moment I realized
I needed help.
- It's a really defeating feeling,
knowing that this is something
you have no control over.
- I thought after that moment,
"I just need to hold my baby.
"I don't ever want this to happen again
"and something has to change."
- Being a stay at home
mom was really isolating
but I felt like I kind of came out of it
when I started exercising and
hanging out with other moms.
- I started feeling better when I could
wake up to my baby every morning
and he just makes everything better
and everything worthwhile.
- To all the mothers going through this,
surround yourself with people who get it
because you're not alone.
- I know there's so
much pressure right now
to be like a perfect mom.
You have to be honest,
you have to let people in
and let them know what
you're going through.
- If you are out there
and you are struggling,
I want you to know that
it is going to get better.
- I'm a mother and I'm vulnerable
but I am capable.
- And I am fighting every day.
- And I'm doing the best that I can.
- And struggling with
postpartum depression
didn't make me weak but
becoming victorious over it,
that's what made me strong.
- We have lost way too many moms
so please stay with us.
Find yourself a community
and keep fighting.
("There's Still Time")